Oh gross has his eye on equities a
little further east he nailed the worst
bond sell-off since 1998 when he called
German bunds the quote short of a
lifetime now he's come out with a
similar call on Chinese stocks he says
the next short of a lifetime could be
China's shenzhen index he says not just
yet let's get out of Bloomberg News
reporter Richard frost / in Hong Kong
Richard break down exactly what Bill
Gross is talking about hit well just do
I just talk about what happened in
Shenzhen after those comments he almost
looked very clever when we saw the
shenzhen composite plunge 6.1 percent in
a very short space of time he then
looked even cleverer we're saying not
yet for that short because that index
then recruit almost all those losses
within just just a similar short space
of time what he's looking at is what he
called an almost hyperbolic climb in the
schengen composite which to me seems a
bit of an understatement this index is
gained are almost triple in the last 12
months that made its market can't be
larger than the whole of the UK when it
looks at when you come to stock markets
you cannot lose in incheon journey hampi
an elder lose there's only i think five
of the some 1,700 companies on the index
have actually fallen this year and with
valuations now when you look at
projected price to earnings the highest
in the world you look at any stock
market 44 times projected earnings
nasdaq is only 22 you can see why he
thinks this is a market poison decline
you can also see why doesn't think it
should bet against it just yet that wall
of money is still there but as that
volatility show today people are getting
more and more nervous about where this
markets heading Richard I guess the
takeaway as Chinese equities don't like
Thursday morning's if you look at the
last couple of weeks for me there's
another big story underlying the the
sell-off in the early session anyway the
IPO story china national nuclear power
hoping to raise two billion dollars i
hear the bids were quite a bit higher
than that
just a little bit some too sorry some
270 billion dollars i mean if you look
at again you gotta look at the
performance if you look at what the some
140 IPOs that have happened in China
this year they've gained on average five
hunt more than five hundred percent I
mean you wonder why those bids weren't
even higher it's almost impossible to
lose you know what people are doing is
loading up on debt putting it in there's
guaranteed this also fits in with what
the Chinese government wants instead of
this company raising a load of dirt
through selling bonds to build nuclear
reactors that can help reduce the
country's Alliance and coal you know
they can raise that money from ordinary
investors of course the risk is you know
how how much further can can these IPOs
go but at the moment there's certainly
no sign that interest in them and demand
for getting into them at early stage is
going to go away Richard frost fantastic
work if you haven't seen that article
check out bloomberg com i'll tweet it
when i get off there